Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call and we will get started.
Okay, our reminder is that everybody to use the member site for any updates and there'll be two weeks in the next two.
There'll be two Zoom calls in the next two months that we will not have a Zoom call. One will be next week.
So there's going to be no Zoom call next week and then no Zoom call on July 10th.
I'm going to be traveling those two days and it's just going to be impossible in the past.
I've done Zoom calls even while I've been traveling and sometimes it worked and sometimes it was a royal disaster.
So I'm just not going to do them. Those two travel dates.
Reminder to self-schedule if you need to and let's jump on to your questions.
What is the difference between right technology and red light therapy?
Can you use both simultaneously and what's the main purpose for red light therapy?
So red light therapy or light therapy in general, those therapy units use a specific wavelength of light.
And that has its benefits typically to the skin but it can have benefits to emotions as well.
But that's as far as it goes. So the difference in they're not really in that you can't really they're not at the same category.
So right technology is using light frequencies, but the frequencies are that you're using are specific to a condition.
So we're using frequency specific to a specific cancer. Let's say if you have prostate cancer, you're running prostate cancer frequencies.
If you're trying to kill streptococcal bacteria, you're running back frequencies specifically for that.
So it's they're completely different. Can you run them at the same time?
Yes, you can because they're completely different frequencies different, just like running a P E M F, which is electrical frequencies that has a totally different purpose and ready to write.
Yes, you can run them at the same time.
So in our follow up call and Monday, you looked over my supplements for antioxidants to stop whenever the MMS protocol here are the other supplements not in your protocol that I'm taking are any of these possible interferences with MMS protocol, which is an oxidative protocol.
The D3 is not so you can continue to use that.
The apigenin is not you can use that a trimethyl glycemic is not you can continue to use that.
That's fine red clover, chaperale, but you this is antitumeral and good for the lungs that's fine cats claw is fine apricot pine.
None of these are antioxidant protocols, so you're fine on all of these.
So the idea is if you're doing an oxidative protocol, which most of you listening to this are doing some sort of oxidative protocol, so understand if this is new terminology to you look at the I wrote a blog post about
hard to see oxidative stress to kill cancer, I think that's the name of the blog.
Reading that will help you understand that reading my book will help you understand that I wrote about this back in 2010 when I originally wrote the book of that you see that for cancer patients not to use excess antioxidants.
Many of the natural treatments for cancer are oxidative all the standards of care treatment for cancer, I shouldn't say all but chemotherapy is oxidative.
The idea is that cancer cells are already at this tipping point of oxidative stress causing lethal death of the cell causing lysis of the cell.
So if you can help tip it over with a greater form of oxidative stress than you could kill the cancer that's why I like using the hydrogen peroxide in direct contact with cancer can be helpful can help kill the cancer.
Hydro peroxide is an oxidative therapy, so that gives you the idea so I didn't want this person to be at the oxidants.
Are you familiar with the primal trust program where you train your brain and make a nerve, your cells will transform from being shut down for safety to open it up to detoxify you know of any to know of other programs to consider.
So the primal trust if you look it up we've had somebody else ask me this question a few months back I looked it up it's kind of I just did not crazy about it because it's kind of a new age type approach to.
You know call me you know that's just not what I'm into we have some patients that are into yoga and deep meditation and all that kind of stuff but I don't judge you for doing that that's not where I'm at from a spiritual perspective so that's not something I would do.
It's you know they make a lot of claims and so just be careful of that I do give the on our website on the blog post I have links to it on the member site and on different courses information about parasympathetic stimulation and sympathetic nervous system calming those are neurological functional neurology exercises to.
That would take up you know a good half hour of your day if you're going to do that on a daily basis I think that's going to have a greater effect to stimulate vagal nerve function to stimulate cranial nerve 10 stimulate your parasympathetics and to call me or sympathetic your opposite of that so I think that would be a better thing to do.
Chat question I've looked into retraining the brain dot com dot new agey okay that's a new thing there's all sorts of different.
Brain exercising programs out there I mean I have a degree in functional neurology as well I used to do a lot of functional neurology used to do we actually I own that we're a feedback center where we did your feedback with brain.
Right master or feedback it can be extremely beneficial but that's neuro feedback with neuro feedback equipment that's not new age or anything functional neurology is just straight an enemy understanding neurology and how neurons work and how you can calm down different things and stimulate other things and understanding the metabolic activity that goes on with their transmitters so.
The there's there's brain centers that are out there typically geared for 80 D80 HD kids and learning disabled kids dyslexia et cetera and that can be extremely beneficial we used to work with a lot of kids with those types of conditions that were on the spectrum and it can be extremely beneficial I will say that if.
If getting a handle of your neurology with you know it's anxiety and having to deal with hypersympathetic stimulation and so do what that means yet to understand the difference between parasympathetic and sympathetic so look at that blog post go to the others clinic dot com search for parasympathetic and you'll get a video that describes what we're talking about here.
But you do need to deal with inflammation in the brain if you're like I just cannot get over this this you know obsessive compulsive issues that I have this anxiety issues that I have.
You know if you're dealing with those neurological issues and you have a conscious awareness that that exists in going on in your life and that this is better.
It's been an issue for a long time you have to look at sources of inflammation so I'd also recommend the video that is called neural inflammation if so if you search on the.
The colors clinic website again I also have that video posted on multiple courses it's called neural inflammation neural inflammation is what you want to search for you'll get a 30 minute video talking about microglial private and neural inflammation.
So a lot of people that have neuro inflammation which ends up causing hyper sympathetic tone for them to be stuck in so they're stuck in a hyper sympathetic tone reading their constantly anxious or just can't settle down can't let things go they have OCD issues those can can be due to all sorts of things that that condition can be due to all sorts of things.
But it certainly do to increase inflammation of the brain and increase glutamate in the brain and there's ways to deal with that from a functional neurology perspective I have downloadable PDF sheets on parasympathetic stimulating exercises and downloadable sheet on exercises that could help calm the sympathetic response.
But also dealing with it from a neuro metabolic standpoint of decreasing the inflammation of the brain and inflammation of the brain can be can be increased by all sorts of different triggers that can stimulate it increase inflammation of the brain toxicity issues post concussive issues food sensitivity.
So if you have a lot of food sensitivities it's going to cause inflammation in the body and it's going to cause inflammation in the brain. So that's where healing the gut is so important as well so dealing with those things is important so I implore you to watch that video called neuro inflammation and you can look at the blog post.
Go to colors clinic.com and look for search for neuro inflammation and you'll see that video that will help that also search for parasympathetic and you'll see the blog post and the video that explains the difference between those and downloadable sheets on how to stimulate your parasympathetic and calm your sympathetic.
Those are real life things that really do work that are straight neurology and they don't have any spiritual connotations to them.
My oncologist is recommended I do genetic testing using a blood sample to possibly find more treatment options have you heard of effective or safe treatments resulting from these tests.
Yes for sure that there are different genetic issues that can suggest a specific treatment option from standards of care.
So if they're recommended you do that and and you have in their pain for it and your chance is covering that I've always said if they're going to do a full genetic workup on you because it's going to be different than what we did on you if we if we did genetic workup on you.
They're going to be looking for timber suppressor genes and they're looking for specific genes that are being studied for specific treatment pathways and if you're open to doing standards of care that might open another doorway so if they're going to it's going to be covered under your insurance I for sure go for that and do that yes.
I am using a product to increase GHA copper which is supposed to increase pluripotent stem cell production will this increase stem cancer stem cell production as well.
So GHK is peptide therapy so it can increase growth and increase mitochondrial function so I would not personally use this I am not in favor of peptide therapy with cancer patients.
It's just to me it doesn't make sense to me you're you're greatly increasing the survival ship of a cancer cell.
If it's anything's going to be stimulating growth and health of cells per se it can stimulate cancer replication and can stimulate health of cancer cells.
The same reason why you typically wouldn't use glutathione and antioxidants with cancer same concept I would say no to this.
I started taking HMET that's called HMET binder supplement to bind micotoxins I've noticed my urine is murky brown color similar to the color of HM and HMET is this to be expected while taking it to have any suggestions and how long to take it taking two capsules per day they'll be enough for 60 days.
I don't know I mean quite honestly there's lots of different reasons why your urine could be discolored and it certainly could be due to that supplement especially if there's you know more direct correlation I've never had this before I started taking the supplement immediately notice a change in the color of my urine.
Certainly could be excreting micotoxins understand HMET binder is not going to be solely specific to micotoxins so you could be binding other toxins and poisons as well so I would say that this is probably a good sign so the other thing that could make your urine darker color is B vitamins.
So I don't know if your diet has increased your B vitamins that's another possibility but there's other things as well I would say you take it for at least 60 days the amount of time it takes to get rid of micotoxins in your body depends on A the rate of your detoxification but it also depends on B the quantity of micotoxins.
That you have and see maybe most important to deal with is if you have current exposure so I'll give you an example of current exposure person did a micotoxin test knew that there was mold in this townhouse that they were living in had the townhouse that they were living in completely redone
and cleaned by mitigation outfit that was contracted to mitigate mold dealt with they felt like dealt with everything in the townhouse however none of the neighbors wanted to get their house checked of course you're living with walls that are connected walls.
You can't you know obviously tear out sheet rock and necessarily the townhouse I don't think they went to that extent so and then they retested six I think it was about three to six months later I don't know and they had different elevated micotoxins so they had current exposure so it's really hard to get better if you have current exposure so that's why I highly recommend if you have elevated micotoxins to get your space tested.
Through that immunolytic slab and if you want information on the immunolytic slab go to our blog post again and look up just start searching mold that said I think the blog post says inexpensive mold testing for your home been going through this metastonic breast cancer journey for over a year with major spine surgery to boot.
I was 125 pounds and I'm 88 pounds as I just gained two pounds in the last two months of this 30. I'm literally skinned bones and I've been eating as much protein as I possibly can lately my abdomen is swollen and very hard like I'm pregnant I don't know if I didn't realize it before but anything I eat or drink just seems to swell me up.
I eat oatmeal for breakfast with berries drink a smoothie with greens first for lunch and eat meat and vegetables for dinner and that's all I can handle swelling as gone by is gone by morning.
Is it common for someone by condition experience of the standard belly.
Okay so yeah well first of all when you have a serious disease especially when you do medications or surgery or anything to try to combat that disease you have to deal with the gut so you have to deal with issues in the gut.
The more we fail to deal with the gut I know when we're hyper focused on killing cancer we can ignore cell of the basics and that is to our detriment.
So a couple things come to mind as first time me reading this question and a person says I have swollen got look like I'm almost pregnant and it's big to stand in belly.
My first day is fluid in the abdomen but if it's gone by morning then that's not it so that's a good sign.
If it's distention due to inflammation of the gut that would be the that would be the next most common thing is you're going through a series of differential diagnosis.
It's distention of the gut so you think of how can you calm down the gut you got to start with some gut healing things you can certainly do some testing to see if there's any you know foods that are causing inflammation but.
Baseline support for the gut is as HCl with digestive enzymes so go go back to the blog and get got blog post to get in search hypochloridria that's your basic support for the gut if you're not taking HCl with digestive enzymes with your foods so you're eating as much protein as possible protein has to be broken down you know in by a good.
Production of your mark acid in your stomach so you don't have really good production of hydrochloric acid in your stomach you're not going to be breaking down your proteins in your stomach and then you need your pancreas to create a good amount of pancreatic enzymes to help break further break down that protein into amino acids in the two on them in the first part of the small test it so.
Helping support that process is important because we've been through a lot in our body has been ravaged you know our stomach decreases in production of hydrochloric acid are pancreas struggling and doesn't produce as much.
Digestive enzymes are phase three pathway in the liver production of bile is reduced so we're not producing as much lipase through bile and we have mal digestion so supporting digestion which is the breakdown of food into particles so that we can absorb it is number one number two is supporting the health of the gut so.
Adding things like you know butarate and slippery and we don't want glutamine as a cancer patient but think of things that will help heal the gut deglycerized licorice marshmallow marshmallow craft marshmallows they don't work but the herb marshmallow and things like that things that are going to be gut healing.
Aloe product that will be gut healing a good product from Zybage it is this GI sooth that I talked about a few weeks ago that is chewable because it can heal the soft against it can heal the stomach and it can help heal the first part of the small intestine which is so important so taking HCO with digestive enzymes.
Taking like a GI sooth to help heal the gut and start that healing product process and gut taking our tributerate from designs for health that I think it's tributer and supreme is really good.
What do you have bloated it's not uncommon that you have sebum which is small intestinal bacterial overgrowth so you got bacteria that's supposed to be only in the larger test and migrates into the small intestine and that causes problems looking at your diet as far as you know cleaning up gluten and dairy if you haven't those are the things that I would look at with the standard belly.
And then digging deeper if you once you if person says I'm doing all those things then if you're doing all those things then you start digging deeper and doing the Syrex array 10 panel to see if there's specific foods that are just causing inflammation or like some people find that there's a lot of foods that are causing inflammation and it's just getting back to the basics of gut healing is the is a key component that is often overlooked when you're trying to deal with the serious disease.
Since taking your suggested supplements of burberry apricot B17 and osteo-K do any of these have the potential of causing nausea.
Yes for sure the B17 the apricot power probably most likely component of causing nausea the burberry probably not osteo-K probably not.
So the osteo-K is little bit of calcium not too much calcium very high content of the vitamin K and in the form of MK4 which is what you want to get to calcium it to the bone.
Probably the B17 so I would just take it with food all three of these can be taken with food so I would get some food in your tummy that was probably what's going on.
My oncologist agreed to write order orders for monthly CEAN's CA2729 tumor marker labs.
He said those are the only relevant ones for me. Is that good enough?
Back when I had active tumors I ran the CA153 and 199 none of them were ever really out of range except for the first 153
and then everything went down after that.
Well is that good enough? Well I'd say no I mean it's better than not running any of them but especially this last comment the your 153 was out of range at one point of time or was elevated at one point of time that's going to be probably the one that would be elevated again.
You know your cancer you know came back as active so I would make the argument that this is the one that was elevated before could you at least run this and you don't get it.
Is it any skin off their bones to run that again you know good as sex here's a person with history and breast cancer.
Why did they have to be argumentative why won't insurance paid for two more tests but to cost them $20 or something give me a break it's just so stupid.
Yeah I mean I'm not knocking you I mean just do whatever you can but I would make the argument that this one was out of range before could you please just run this one again as well so yeah it's frustrating.
My small improvement seed with avoiding my red zone foods for my food allergy tests so think this person did the Syrex 10 has reversed so I'm back to no regular moments and I managed to get a cold I never get sick.
I've noticed that in the past that if I do a restrictive diet of any sort or detox all veggie diet I tend to get sick.
Any thoughts on adjustments to make I'm still not getting any less noticeable bloating by Ted or so foods are high carb high histamine etc but all in the green zone.
I've got you to gut course by Steven right his main point seems to me the old formula of gut powder is in part of scene glutamine etc are outdated seems he's recommending really increasing the butarate for example he supplements cells 500 milligrams so understand what butarate is butarate is calcium and magnesium butarate is butaric acid butaric acid is made.
In the gut bio amino acids and from amino acids your gut makes butaric acid and that is the made fuel source for your endothelial cells so yeah that's why I highly recommend taking butarate as a gut healer got support butarate but also
get help calm down what I mentioned in that other person's question is sebo if the person has small intestine the bacterial overgrowth which how do you get small intestine bacterial overgrown well you get that by the most common thing is taking any sorts of medications it throws off of your throws off your gut.
Microbiota you can get your the microbiota that is limited your larger intestine that didn't get killed off overgrow into the smaller intestine that's a small intestine bacterial overgrowth is one way you know you have it I mean you could do a test for a GI panel will test for sebo there's specific sebo test that test for different gases in a breath test.
As well but one way you can have a big clue that you know you have sebo is it fiber makes you worse so if taking like a fiber supplement makes you worse that it's pretty much guaranteed you have sebo and the treatment for sebo the sebo protocol really is to go off of all fiber and to go on butarate for a period of time
and it doesn't take that long to get that back into balance and but I would disagree with steve it right that the gut formula is our out of outdated all those things that we discussed um that like zinc caracid cardacene and glutamate and slippery album and yellow and all those things are healing to the gut.
It's just because you know using butarate is the latest and greatest because understand so a little bit history butarate wasn't a supplement and tell fairly recently and butarate is made by your god through break down of food.
And when butarate came out as a supplement then it was the latest and greatest thing but it didn't it didn't like you know substitute for other gut healing herbs and things.
It is just another thing to use to help get your gut in balance I would highly suggest you if you're looking for a substitute for the substitute the supplement he says try to look at the designs for help try butarate tributer and supreme I think it is it's three different forms of butarate I thought it couldn't hurt to get laser focused info while I'm dealing with this problem absolutely get as much information as you possibly can.
Okay so back to the chat here can saturated fat cause insulin resistance can burberry kill good bacteria.
Burberry can burberry kill good bacteria.
Well burberry is it can kill bacteria so burberry is your treatment of choice or at least one of the treatments of choice when you're trying to kill HP lower I burberry is not is not an antibiotic so it's not going to go in there and wipe out your gut flora and destroy all your good bacteria.
I wouldn't be concerned about that whatsoever so I'd be more concerned that I have an imbalance in in my bacteria you know particularly or at least one strong possibility is HP lower I overgrown and that's where burberry will be most beneficial.
So I would be concerned about that as far as saturated fat causing insulin resistance I'm sure there's a connection of that there could be a connection it's a lot of there's been a lot of flaws in the studies of saturated fat so.
I don't know if there are valid studies out there on that but if a person is having insulin resistant issues and notices that diet is there consuming a lot of saturated fat it's something to experiment with.
If I have an MRI with contrast what do I take to get rid of the contrast so the contrast used with MRIs is typically a gadolinium so gadolinium is technically heavy metal and so how do you get rid of that well your body is detoxy that so your body is constantly trying to detox.
So the more you can support your detoxification pathways using you know support of your liver using coffee enemas use hot packs over your liver you're going to help detox that we do have an MRI homeopath a gadolinium homeopath on our store that you could use to help pull that out as well.
Is it necessary for everybody to take the gadolinium homeopath if they're going to do an MRI with contrast no it's not necessary it's just another precaution but you know anything you are doing to detoxify is going to help detoxify gadolinium is detox through the liver phase one phase two pathways like any other toxic so.
But if you're interested in something specific for that you could call our store and ask Megan about the gadolinium homeopath or you could look up on the store MRI detox MRI homeopath and you'll see that available.
I have constant pain in my growing from it to we're growing on my bladder pressing on a nerve can the right machine be helpful what settings what can be done for constant pain well the right is going to be most beneficial to be running the programs that I wrote for you to kill the cancer so as a cancer decreases in size then the pressure the physical pressure on that nerve.
You would think at least would decrease as well in the pain would decrease.
We have had people that run the pain program on the right there's pain bio one and pain bio two there may be another few pain programs there could also think of inflammation run inflammation program there's several programs for inflammation.
Try those programs I would try them I mean some people have used those programs and told them it was like miracle told us it was like a miracle some people said I've done it and any good well because it's just didn't that program specific frequencies didn't help that person.
And some people have just said it's a miracle so I would try those those two programs also I would just try to run the your day programs as much as possible to so again when I was really really sick by cancer I was just running by same I wasn't running different programs on us they have it's just running the same you know program for annual carcinoma over and over again the most 24 hours a day.
And that's really what turned me around turning 60 in a few weeks and wrestling with everyone needs a colonoscopy an age 55 or older I had a pet CT scan three years ago when that have showed any issues what are your thoughts on these things.
Well we've had patients that have discovered colon cancer via a colonoscopy and so so it's hard for me to not colonoscopies but at the same sense I never had a colonoscopy and I don't plan on ever getting a colonoscopy so
But I'm not saying you should do as I do there's pros and cons to a colonoscopy so just like any medical procedure this is not a non invasive one obviously so yeah I mean especially if you've had a pet scan and CT scan three years ago it certainly would decrease the need for a colonoscopy no because
yeah I mean one could argue that well that is just um you know what if you have polyps growing now that could be plucked out that could be precancerous yeah you could make that argument so yeah it's hard for me to knock doing a colonoscopy what it is you know kind of
the only preventative procedure that medicine really does but in the same sense you know people have had issues with them too or can I just get a cologuard test a cologuard test is actually the same technology for those who have been with me for you know five plus years remember we had the IVG test
so the IVG test uses the cologuard test I should say uses the exact same technology as the IVG test there literally the exact same technology IVG went the way I'm trying to sell it to practitioners that would you know that were you know trying to do preventative care and cancer care
cologuard went the way of selling out to a pharmaceutical company that then got it approved for insurance function so in cologuard still around so we'll figure people didn't want to pay cash for the test so I don't know if they will do cologuard if you had it answer diagnosed the past
because it could throw that off if you still have cancer elsewhere or something but you can certainly check into that any idea why I lost improvement on my gut healing protocol I read that eating rice increases butarate so maybe that sudden change since I didn't normally eat rice cause the regular bowel movements but only for a while should I add a small amount of chicken back yellow zone item
yeah I would say I would say try that again get the yellow zone items things you want to add back soon or then later so yes you got it and this is going to be experimental for you so yeah that would be a good experiment maybe I'm not getting a protein that's why I got a cold you could be onto something there totally I had white I had blood labs run a couple days before I started having symptoms
and I don't think anything was off hemoglobin or hemantichrit so if you look for what getting a cold you look for if your white blood cells were off and your breakdown of white blood cells called the differential was off too but yeah I think you're onto something I would maybe think of doing that adding chicken back with making some chicken soup would be a good thing I think that might be good
what are your thoughts on taking a moxicillin after cavitation surgery my pathology report came back off the charge and he said it was most extensive or did he say most expensive or do you say extensive report you ever got back so you're talking about your pathology report for the cavitation I hope and so if they're doing the cavitation surgery
hopefully you're going to a biological dentist that's coming from using the moxicillin is a preventative measure as they're going to they're cleaning things up they're spewing out a lot of bacteria that's the idea and if they're spewing a lot of bacteria the chance of you getting a bacterial infection goes up
and that's not uncommon and even if you're getting a tooth extracted many times you'll be given a prescription or a moxicillin because the chance of getting an infection because of a recent extraction goes up
is there anything wrong with taking a moxicillin for several days well yes and no so taking a moxicillin any antibiotic is going to of course throw off your gut microbiota however there's been research it says taking and probiotic with your antibiotic greatly reduces the negative effects of the microbiota
interesting in the study it didn't even make any difference what variety of probiotics the person took which was very interesting I thought but just taking a probiotic reduced the damage of the microbiota however there's still going to be damage and how do you get your microbiota back by eating a variety of different foods
that are good organic foods that dump have natural microbiota in them that you're recolonizing your gut so you gotta weigh it out you know it's I took some moxicillin honestly I don't know maybe a month ago but I started getting lime symptoms really bad I felt really ill and I thought this is exactly how my lime side headlines three times
and I always caught up the acute phase and I always took an antibiotic I understand this is the fourth time I've ever taken antibiotics in my life and I only took it for two days so if it was lime I don't know for sure positive I didn't do a test because I think immediate lime tests are worthless because the time you get the test back you could have moved into a chronic phase
so but it felt the exact same I didn't notice a bullseye but my lifestyle is when I'm not in the office doing things like this I'm outside we have a humongous garden we have 20 acres I'm constantly working on the yard and so constantly picking up ticks and stuff like that too and then deer ticks you just don't know so it's some
you know there's pros and cons to it I just knew how sick I got with lime disease that it was worth taking two days of a moxicillin and taking the probiotics and pulpit it back up I don't think there was you know a whole lot of ill effect on my gut though there are always this effect on your gut so you gotta weigh out the pros and cons of those things so
I think it's something like that it might be wise to take antibiotic for a short period of time any other questions wherever there will not be a Zoom call next week and traveling on Wednesday so no Zoom call next week but we back the following week so please still submit your questions
and good call all right love all you guys we praying for you and everybody have a great week and let me know if there's anything else I can do all right bye